vous préférez vivre dans un monde où
tout le monde a bonne conscience vous
voulez vivre dans un monde qui
fonctionne face aux guerres modernes les
options militaire ou diplomatique
ne fonctionne pas toujours
parfois on a besoin d'une troisième
option
c'est nous d'après le gouvernement nous
n'existons pas nous sommes des fantômes
mais les fantômes bien réel et on se
tape les misions bernad
je vais tâcher d'être clair et concis 4
kilos et demi d'isotopes radioactifs en
disparu c'est un c pour rendre six
grandes villes inhabitat il sait
exactement où il se trouve
restez vous est annoncé partout qu'est
ce que vous voulez je veux sortir du
pays
il est recherché pour espionnage on est
en train de parler d'un petit flic
corrompu si vous êtes là c'est que votre
fuite n'est pas si petit que ça
attention vous faites attention vous
avez des hommes qui se promène dans
notre ambassade
vous avez été plutôt coup
peut avoir confiance en vous mettez moi
dans un avion pour les états unis et je
vous dirai ce que c'est une opération en
vue roanne
le but de la mission est de livrer ce
pack est ici à la borne basse de ce nom
les pc qui peut démarrer
gasmi
[Musique]
ils sont à moto
michael a dit m
on en compte quatre
la main de dieu accordé tirer
km 2 km notre avion ne peut rester au
sol que dix minutes c'est loupé ses
fenêtres ils sont bons
jusqu'à ce qu'on meurt tous si c'est le
jeu du jour je marque un but
voyez que vous êtes dangereux pipi je
suis un tueur qui passe pour iron c'est
bondé et analystes allemands du monde et
quoi tu es ypersele
parce que tu es complètement barge merci
rien